[Music]
[Applause]
hey guys
anna welcome back to the lehigh pen show
which is as
always powered by icon plus so i'm going
to give you guys a really quick news
announcement from them so
the government of juju island revealed
its five-year plan to put five billion
dollars into the island to turn it into
korea's blockchain hub
it has plans to target digital
technologies using icons decentralized
id for public services so as always
brilliant news coming from the icon
network
i also want to say thank you to my
sponsors block fi
i use them to earn about 8.6
interest on my usdc um so what i'm going
to do is i'm going to leave the link
and so you guys can sign up and actually
get 25 if you um join with them
i'm going to put it in the comments put
it in the description so um if you fancy
grabbing 25
then go for it so joining me today um is
a very
interesting guest i've been super
excited to chat to her we're talking
about two very different topics we're
talking about nfts
and we're talking a little bit about
feminism so it is
margaret root welcome to the show how
are you
hey thanks leah i'm doing good it's so
good to have you we've been trying to
catch up for
ages how are you doing i'm doing i'm
doing really well in um
i'm in eastern oregon and surviving so
i'm actually going on my first vacation
since
february on sunday so oh my god where
are you off to
go oh my gosh wow is that like a normal
thing for is that like a normal place
for americans to go or is that just
as exotic as it sounds um actually they
just opened up so hawaii
has been pretty strict about letting
travelers and you had it it was a force
to eat quarantine
and so just now actually you can go if
you have
passed a rapid covet test you're allowed
to go and play on the island
and you have to pay a ridiculous amount
of money to get these covered tests like
we do
um it's a hundred dollars that's a lot i
think that's ridiculous
i mean yeah well i guess you don't have
to uh
you can get it back in two to three days
right if you don't want it
yeah but i mean so with us like if you
don't want to quarantine
a lot of the time you might have to
spend let's say 200 pounds just to get
um just to get a result to sort of prove
that you don't have it
so yeah pretty crazy but
i want to talk about the nft scene
because you are the ceo
of blockhead games and you've been up to
so much recently
nfts have kind of just like blown up
towards the end of this year
it is the year of d5 but we can't end it
without chatting about nft so
firstly what have you been up to sort of
break it down for us
well i've actually been playing in a lot
of the different
exciting spaces including deep and nfcs
and watching gaming um
so i guess blockade has been around for
over two years
um we've been working on this our
mainstream title
it's called neon district it's a
cyberpunk rpg
it takes kind of the most cutting-edge
um aspects of what you can do with
non-changeable tokens today
with the tools that we've all built
across the developer space mostly i'm
going to speak to the ethereum space um
that's where we've been really focused
even though neon district itself is
launching automatic
network which is a layer two of ethereum
um
so anyways what we've done is uh play
so i'll keep it very high level but the
thing about non-fungible tokens is you
can do really neat crafting systems
composability you can create new objects
out of other pre-existing objects
because of the unique nature of having
their uniquely identified assets
so with that in mind we can create
really neat systems
in which to play with them um my
background
in gaming in the blockchain sector in
general goes back to 2014.
i'm mostly focused on bitcoin and
educational experiences
so when non-fungible tokens really took
traction
with the cryptokitties back in december
that's when we decided it was time to do
the game company
because of this new uh basically the new
asset
yeah and you know i always have this
mentality which is if you don't innovate
you're going to be left behind
and that's exactly what you guys have
done yes
and actually painfully so because
yeah yeah bear market that lasted for
three years my
co-founder the smithy tto ben and i
it was tough to survive that bear market
and keep going at that development rate
with the momentum and the um the
optimism
that this would all come back around it
was just a cycle so the
numbers in the space kept building
anyway and we've
all had this energy of you know what
what can we do next
so that has been persistent um the fact
that those
that have been building now are ready to
capture this excitement and enthusiasm
that
money does keep people's attention and
driving
uh the applications of what is possible
yeah was it come i think you should come
a bit closer because it's kind of hard
to hear you i'm like struggling yeah
come a little bit closer it's hot there
we go yeah that's probably a bit better
for us
okay so like you said you know those are
those i've been building this is really
an opportunity for them to sort of like
i guess cash in on that
so my question to you really is i want
to talk about nfts because they are very
controversial you know
a lot of people sort of say um you know
is it really the original so i want to
just sort of start and look at selfies
just for a second okay
so because you know a lot of a lot of
women online um will post a selfie and
then make it
mint it and make it um an nft so
far so where is the value in that right
because two issues for me that i see
like immediately the first issue is
let's say i post a selfie um
in august it's now october i put it i
create it as an nft
surely someone can just go down my
profile and find that selfie so am i
understanding this incorrectly
and then secondly once let's just say i
never even posted a selfie in the first
place
you can just go on let's say like
wearable or whatever it is wherever
you're selling it
and you just screenshot it and then you
have it because at the end of the day i
go on you answer that first and then
i'll jump in
um what's interesting about
non-profitable tokens is they have
something called metadata extensions
so this supports not only just image
files but also sound files we're seeing
now
people like rac and um and lau
which are very famous indian musical
artists enter the space and they are
starting to play with what's possible
with the sound files
so those metadata extensions that
support the non-fungible assets that's
all transferable information
with the token so as an application
developer
even though you can take um let's say
you can take a screenshot of a game
character a fortnight game character
does that mean that you can play with
that fortnite game character in fortnite
it doesn't so the the asset
and the attributes of that asset are um
are like basically that's all data
associated with the token
so when i for example at block so in
blockade games
if we want to support a music library of
um
rac and blouse tokens then we can when a
player is playing
they can have a specialized and
customized music library
and that they play and um drop these
different beats when they're in pvp
battle against their opponent
based on the tokens they've collected
that we can just read directly from
their wallet
so the the ability of having a unique
token id which is the
one of the unique features of an nft
plus the uh smart contract component of
the nft itself so it's just um
the it's not the value so that's where
the value i guess is in the experience
i mean yes people talking about this so
therefore also when i i've done
controversial selfies
just to play around um wait can i just
say selfies are not controversial like
what's actually what sorry just pause on
that for a second
continue
it is controversial that i have a video
game company
that i put selfies and um
i can't be trusted if i am attractive at
all
so that is the argument that
that people try to push and in reality
like that is completely
like ridiculous so anyways in playing
with that uh argument
posted a selfie in response to it and
because of that moment and what that
selfie was
immediately tokenized it and shared it
on the same thread
um in which someone purchased it and it
was priced for
a decent amount of money like maybe a
thousand dollars
um but the point is it came from my it
came from my marketplace
it is definitely um like i minted it and
a fan purchased it and so in any of my
future coin artist tokens that i meant
i may as a game developer or application
developer decide to do something fun
with them
but the point is fans actually really
just love being able to participate and
have that relationship
we're gonna see this i think um with
influencers streamers people that have
personal brands across the internet
uh this is a new way to monetize and
it's also an experience that fans are
wanting to opt into i have a question
though
so so you sold that selfie that was
already posted
online okay so i understand that okay so
i understand you know
um that value comes from what kind of
experience you can have with it so if
you're talking about a character from
fortnite then
i can totally understand the value in
that because you can't exactly
it's not it's not just about looking at
it it's about actually like playing with
it right so i get that
but it's something like a selfie i guess
anything has value
um according to the market right so if
people you know agree it has value it
has value so
i think to sort of say that it doesn't
have value or it's a scam or this or
that doesn't make sense i just
struggle to find the value in it so i
would love to chat to
um whoever spent you know a thousand
dollars because
why did they not just screenshot it like
honestly if the value
for them was just to you know have your
photo
just to have your photo surely they
could just screenshot it and it's it's
the same so that's that's where it's not
it's the value isn't in just the photo
it's that
it um who it came from when it was uh
created who owned it the ledger that
history of
who's owned it the fact that you can
display this ownership
across multiple different marketplaces
so let's say
in the central land in this 3d whatever
space
people have the ability to basically put
together galleries
that display what's in their wallet you
also have
visual galleries uh and
there's there's there's just an uh
ownership component to it where
it's provable uh you can trace back that
it came from me
and that um i could also like
put an autograph on it there's something
called uh scribe
where i can basically put a customized
message on this nft
and actually as it trades hands other
people can put
autographs on it as well um or messages
yeah so that it's the fact that it has
this okay so the real value this is my
argument with a lot of things
being valuable is the story and
blockchain has a way to basically
especially with non-principal tokens
really capture that story and you're
able to
um yeah just speak to like when it
happens
but you know what actually i brought
this up the other day and this really
like made a lot of people mad was this
idea that
you could have an nft uh
that actually has no monetary value
whatsoever yes could possibly still be
valuable to someone because of a
sentimental value
and yes that's what i'm saying the
experience in this case
was like you know how if you get a heart
on twitter someone sends you
like like something and they give a
heart okay now imagine that
you do something and someone sends you
an nft card
um but when they do this they don't
actually lose that heart from their
wallet the contract could be designed in
a way where they always maintain
equal amounts of hearts whenever they
send it to you it's actually just one's
being minted in your wallet but they
still keep theirs
and they're essentially saying is it
meaningful at all if for example that
you were to send me a heart after the
show
and whenever i look at my wallet i'm
gonna see that heart and remember
who it came from and why and actually
that history and the date of when it
came
will be there and you could also put in
a special message on that to me
um and from there from there on
i can send other people hearts because
now i have this nft with a special
contract
that mints in this way so you would be
my originating heart
and from there like i would be giving
all my other hearts
i hear you and again it sort of takes
you back to the whole like double
spending
thing do you know what i mean like the
whole idea that like you know
that sort of that was like the sort of
thing that bitcoin you know fixed in the
first place blockchain technology fits
in the first place
you know but that's and i get and i get
that and i get
and so firstly i'm not against it at all
and i think i'm not against nfts in the
slightest and i think if
if you can make money or you know if
there's value if people find value in it
then sell it like they don't see a
problem with that you know like if
somebody will pay that money for it then
that's completely fine from a business
perspective
um but what confuses me
and i hear what you're saying i hear
what you're saying the fact that there's
one makes it rare
right i get that like it would lose
value if if i sent you a heart but i
still keep my own heart
i get that money like so remove the idea
that this thing like purposely that what
i just talked about
is not meant to be valuable at all it's
not going to have a marketplace
it is not going to be valuable what's
valuable is just the engagement
it's just the fact that like you have
your wallet that has your
valuable assets um especially you know
we're talking about ethereum your
ethereum assets and
you can receive those things that are
just fun and playful
and they can be tied to social
experiences
that in itself are just telling a story
so when you look at someone's wallet
you can see different aspects of people
they've interacted with
you know games they've played because of
what they're holding and
their money but like i think that
the engagement and creative sector where
we're going to take a lot of these
non-printable tokens they don't
necessarily have to have financial value
for people that want to play with them
i think that okay so nfcs in general i'm
definitely on board with i think like
the fact that collectibles
is a thing you know in the physical
sense in a tangible sense whether it be
you're collecting coins stamps
um people collect you know trophies
whatever flowers people collect you know
whatever it is
i get that that's a thing and given
we're moving forward in this
digital world it makes sense that this
would then become digital and
i turned for me that makes absolute
sense and i also hear what you're saying
when you talk about
um in this decentralized world you can
literally have
your gallery of all these different
things that you own like i did an
interview
um with a company i think it's called
terra virtua maybe
you probably know them um and they they
were really cool
they showed me this online digital world
where you can have
all these collectibles and somebody was
really somebody was really cool when
they explained it to me
and they said um you know you have like
an instagram account right
instagram is where you would have all
your pictures
and for someone like my grandpa he
wouldn't understand
why i would want all my pictures sort of
just like there on this instagram
digital thing
as opposed to in a photo album right
so it's so moving collectibles digital
makes sense to me
and then you know putting it on the
blockchain and given the fact that it
has
value you can then trade it and so on
and so on and you can mark you know
which number
or you know of how many has been minted
it is that makes sense i just can't get
my head around the selfie
just giving it like ah the screenshot
it's the screenshot that gets me
and i get that it's not necessarily the
real one but like if there's value but
if they see value in just sort of like
you and they just want to look at you
like a poster
to me that's where i'm just a little bit
unsure well if you have a brand
so let's say miley cyrus is
issuing her it's like buying the
it's like when you buy nikes let's just
jump to the mickey's
yeah you can have the bikie logos
knockoffs but are they
oh okay that's why i get them did nike
mint them and produce them
it's the same thing so like if i but
except it's
it's verifiable and traceable so um
that those nikes were produced on chain
you have the stamp they were
manufactured and produced
and uh they came with a digital token
with the shoes that showed you
that information and that these are
authentic i'm with you
but i'm with you and i totally hear you
and i think it's a great example my only
issue is
this is actually something i think i saw
peter mccormack right
and he wrote because i know he's quite
anti-nfcs and he wrote um
but it's never the original the original
was the selfie that you took
on your phone and then posted onto
twitter that was the original
yeah except it's still i produced it's
still like when an artist
produces the thing to sell
uh and by then that is what the artist
has produced
so like i could make um prints
of you know prince of a piece i make
doesn't mean that that
is not authentically something i made
i hear you i hear you i think i need to
like wrap my head around this a little
bit more i can't quite
i get and i get it to about 90 percent
um 100 it's just from there onwards i
don't know
i'm kind of i'm in like two minds about
it and like i'm actually i actually have
an nft
that um somebody's produced like
somebody's created for me and i want to
sell it it's really really cool
it's like a superhero thing but i can
see the value in it because it's never
because it is the original and it was
cree and it's a piece of artwork and
it's super incredible what they've done
it's really cool like do you really
do you really want to sell it yeah why
not or do you want to hold on to it
oh stop it i don't know i'll see it when
it's ready when it's ready i'll make
that decision
that's the thing about nfts though is
that they have this additional
sentimental
experience to them where a lot of people
will want to
even if it's like just hold on to it
because they like it as opposed to i
know it is really cool
it's really really cool i can't wait
till it's ready i'll give you a sneak
peek
um before but other stuff i wanted to
talk about um
so for everybody watching i know that
they've probably been quite excited
um because you and i talk a lot about um
gender roles we talk a lot about um
feminism what it means in 2020
i know you have a lot of opinions on
this
um so i put out a tweet yesterday for
everyone who wants to know this was
prompted and prompted by coin artist
herself
um so i decided to put out the tweet
which was um
has i think it was i can't remember
something like has feminism um
ruined chivalry so this is
um a stance which men often take um a
stance whereby they sort of say you know
i'm too afraid to open doors for women
and this and that
and i have to say i used to work around
london
as a journalist and for those that don't
know london is huge
and you go on the london underground
there are stairs and not once
in my experience you know carrying all
this heavy equipment up and down the
stairs did a man ever offer
and by the way i know i'm 5'3
just i know maybe that doesn't mean much
to you americans but
i'm quite small so you know all this
equipment is a lot
and not once did somebody offer the only
time somebody offered
was by the time i got gotten to the top
of the stairs
and the man turned around to me and he
said um
oh i was gonna ask but i was afraid i
would offend you
do you want some help and i was like you
wouldn't offend me and plus i'm at the
top of the stairs now so
no so where do you stand on this
what is going wrong so this is
actually i think i've been more afraid
to talk about this topic than any other
ones
in recent history don't be afraid don't
be afraid
because um
i was amazed at the attraction we saw
something like over 5 000
likes and nearly 6k yeah and
and like comments like retweets it's
it's not it's a topic that people
are very passionate about and also have
a very
distinct differentiating personal
opinions on
so i can only speak to this for my
personal you know opinion
and um in i
have i guess face there's two sides
uh in my business world i want to be
treated and respected a certain way
and then in my personal life i want to
be
treated in you know a certain way and i
i have hit
those same friction points where you
have to sit down and explain to somebody
that okay
i know that i am like at my work i'm
tough
and i do a lot of these really ambitious
things but at the same time
i still you know don't want to have to
apologize
for things that like niceties that i
like to have in a relationship
that um of basically being
you know for me i associate it with
being a woman and having like
innate needs that i want to receive from
my counterpart
um and i guess so i find it so i guess
i get um a tongue tied here because i
don't want
it it's tough i don't want to offend
anybody but please
can i can i just say like don't even
don't worry about that everyone's going
to be offended by something and where
and how how do we even define offense
like i could define offense by
you i don't know just saying you don't
offend any
now i'm offended so that doesn't work we
can't we can't go forward with that
mentality it doesn't work you just have
to speak freely so please go on
um so i mean there's in work for example
i have been to different uh groups where
their
women ceo ceos get together and talk
about some of their experiences
and i have heard stories and this is
probably
more common than what i think but of
women for example
being afraid to have families while
they're trying to be ambitious
in the business space the business world
so instead of having families
they um because for many reasons
like freezing their eggs for a later
date
um because they're getting older and and
it's
like the sad part is a lot of the times
i wonder
is it because of this pressure to like
we're not
allowing women to be like you can't be a
mom and successful in the business space
and so you have this pressure where you
have to hide it so much so that we're
gonna
you know put postpone all those things
about ourselves
until much later there's nothing wrong
with doing that it's just that
i want i feel the pressure about you
know
when people want to cry into my personal
life like do i have kids don't i have
kids
um i definitely don't talk about it and
i think that's a personal problem
actually there's a lot of women that are
very confident about who they are and
their truth and on it and i really
respect those women
but i've run into especially
in fundraising or anything else trying
to
keep myself on the same playing field as
a man um
about what i'm bringing to the table and
things that maybe they would judge me
for even subconsciously and try to keep
that
totally off to the side do you think men
would judge you what for
for what exactly if i'm a mom if i'm if
i'm a mom
if i'm married if i'm not married if i
does that matter
like if they judge you does that matter
well it's
it does matter in the when it doesn't
matter when i don't want it to be a
consideration
so i'm in control of what's being talked
about right um
yeah i'm in control of how i want them
to see me
so the information i will offer will be
according to what i'm comfortable
with sharing and i think
that i think that people even women
um even like women investors also
often judge judge you one on your
attractiveness
like if you're too attractive you're not
trustworthy if you're
um and 19 and then also
your personal life like there's there's
a levelness of
trustworthiness or competency that goes
with that as well
and um so it gets really interesting
like how do you be this perfect
and you see this as a mom people tried
to say okay
there's so much pressure in being a
perfect mom it's the same way as being a
woman in the workplace there's so much
pressure to be like this perfect woman
that hits all these boxes uh in order
like that you have to check to be
successful
like i for example i had someone tell me
once that
well you can't uh post uh
attractive photo on social media because
like what woman in the business world
does this that's successful
going to just jump in i have a few
questions because i think your
experience
is slightly different to mine and your
perspective is different to mine
so like you know you might be right
there might be people that judge you
for you know having kids not having kids
by a certain age
or whatever it is being a female trying
to be a successful woman or whatever
balancing that but from my perspective
um
i don't really care and i know that
might sound
i just don't really you know if somebody
i sort of take the mentality now
i i don't tell all men with the same
brush and i don't think all men would
bet against me just because i've never
had a man
and an employee and a male employer bet
against me because i'm female um
and you could talk about you know is
this an age thing is it not an age thing
um but i do i've never ever
had someone bet against me because i'm
not female i've had sexist comments and
things like that
but i think people in general will get
judgments
people in general will get sexist
comments men will get sexist comments
i just think in order to be a um
in order to be a competent human this is
the you know
in order to be a competent human we have
to sort of just say
and so what so if someone was to judge
me
for you know wanting to be
like you know i for wanting to be
successful and sort of being more career
driven than like family driven
you know that's fine i i
it doesn't really bother me and and just
one second and also you're somebody
that's the ceo of their own company
so surely it shouldn't matter even more
like
do you really want to be doing business
with men that look at you and say oh
you're too beautiful so i don't trust
you i mean
they sound like absolutely incompetent
idiots if i'm honest and i would never
want to do business with them i think
somebody i want to do business with is
somebody that can
say okay she looks like x but wow what a
fantastic business plan she's offering
what amazing value she's offering you
know have you ever fundraised before
no i haven't um they're going yeah
so so it there's um it's a whole
it's a game of chess i mean it just is
and it's not like a man is going to come
out and say oh well you're too this for
that
they don't that's not how it works they
ask questions and they make judgments
and that's it like so as you're
successful in these different
conversations why are we not and you
reflect on them
and you work to be better the next time
um
you really start asking you're still
here i'm gonna change my camera
i'm still here going i'm still here i'm
just changing my camera one second you
still
there's some questions that you have to
get really
real with yourself about um why
is this person taking me seriously and
this one not taking me seriously why was
this one so successful in this one not
and you do go back and forth with this
so like for example blockade we raised
about three million dollars which is
pretty good like oh
i think there's only one percent of
startups don't
have raised like of women that have
raised that much because
across um with early stage startups
so i feel very successful in that way
but i can tell you it is hard
and there are yes of course um it's and
if you look
like techstars which was a program i
participated in um
there is a bias against women and from
their research
on on what like their chances of raising
and how much
they would raise according to a male
counterpart um
is it is in a way that they have
launched their own
like fund to support women founders
so and understanding also like why
some of that is um like
it's anyways i guess like i just want to
say that
when you hit those places where you're
you're fundraising and that's
actually why i love watching space so
much is because i pivoted back around to
the more bootstrap model now where we're
um
basically it's revenue and then we're
building around the revenue we have
and moving more organically as opposed
to
fundraising because fundraising is awful
and it takes a ton of time
especially from a founder but um
that's i think where you'll you'll see
the biggest bias come
is when you sit down and you're asking
for money
yeah i think like i think you know i
we can only have a talk from experience
so i i totally hear you
um my perspective you know when hearing
something like that
is is really which i think you're doing
anyway and which is how i tend to
navigate my life is just to keep on
going really
um and i think in life everybody has
privileges and everybody has
disadvantages like i believe there's
female privilege
i believe there's male privilege i
believe there's white privilege i
believe there's black privilege
i believe there's all sorts of privilege
so
my response to that is you know it's a
shame and we just have to keep on going
um but i i want to kind of like stick
with
the idea of like has feminism sort of
ruined
chivalry um because i think it's it's so
interesting and just i'll give you my
opinion straight off the bat
i actually don't think it has so i i
realized that my tweet
saying has feminism ruined chivalry sort
of implied that i think it had
but i actually don't so my perspective
on this
is that those men who were always
chivalrous true
genuine gentlemen i believe they are
still that way
so no matter how much oh no don't hold
the door for me you've just offended me
no matter how much of that rubbish we
keep hearing i do think that
real true genuine gentleman will always
still be like that
what i think it's given it's given the
ones who aren't an excuse
um and a reason to opt out that's those
are my thoughts on if i had to sort of
summarize it into a really sort of small
sentence i've actually had a few
conversations with people
in thinking about like this um and i
would say exactly what you just said is
what my sister said
um my older sister when and i challenged
her a little bit
and said but what about what about that
um that was basically
her takeaway too because i've been told
that basically lots of people say this
the ones that
you know pretty much want to opt out
from that sort of the mannerisms
um here cerberus is basically just being
a gentleman
essentially it's a treat being a
gentleman um
that can you like can we be successful
women
in the world uh that are equal players
on equal footing
and also feel like he made you feel like
we're princesses
for example at the same time okay okay
so
you shouldn't be princessed at work
absolutely not
if you want to be taken seriously no
outside of work and you
so so this is my perspective this is
it's 20 20. you can be a strong
independent woman you can be career
driven and very successful and still be
your princess
inside your own personal relationship
because
because we need to understand that like
okay if we're if we're built
now it's 2020 we're modern women and
we're built in two ways we still have
that innate kind of
biology within us which tells us you
know we want to be nurtured we want to
be nurturing we want a strong man and
whatever that's fine
but we also understand that we've got to
be successful because we want x y and z
and nobody's going to get that for us
but us
we can have both i think and really it's
about sort of optimizing yourself
for both situations does that make sense
i don't think you have to have either or
it's 20 20.
right well so that's i guess i agree
that's how i feel too
but um i think some men i've in
conversations
like sometimes find it hard to balance
that they're because they feel like
oh okay so in one conversation i had
recently started out with
well you know i'll open the door for
someone because i don't want to make it
a thing
and i i want to move on to other
conversations but i respect a woman more
who will open the door for herself
in that conversation though is that what
the man said
yes and but as we were discussing
eventually
um we came to find common ground that in
reality
romantic relationships are more like a
dance where
two different people are doing two
different things in the dance and they
yet are complimentary to each other and
the
act of opening the door if you it's it's
like a gesture in a dance
that you know it's it's thoughtful where
they're showing that they have awareness
that you know we're women we don't ex
like we're not demanding it
in a sense that uh of our subtle
differences and that
it is like pleasing to us yeah
um yeah so like i guess when we think
about
the the give and take take of
what can happen in those behaviors it
let me go to
asking um okay
if women have this expectation of men to
be chivalrous for us to feel like
pleased in the relationship what is it
on our
side that we're delivering and bringing
to the table that pleases them
in a similar way um so
this is where i think my conversation
actually with my sister kind of
got at odds was that um
if we're thinking about all different
types of relationships not just men and
women
you'll see childress on both sides or
you know chivalry animal sites
um but that doesn't mean
respect mannerism right the being
what is what is lady like um but if you
hold these things side by side
actually it feels to me
and this is where i haven't figured out
how i feel about this yet it feels like
to me that society almost
uh if you break down the different
definitions for example like gentlemen
versus gentlewoman or lady
it seems like the woman's side is more
objectified
in general like it's classy it's um
it's it's a different it's like men have
chivalry
which is valiant free you know all these
different
uh descriptions with it whereas the
classy side it's
you know be smart pretty and
it's just much more shallow so i think
there's more depth there in which women
like have fought for that equal footing
because we are more than just those
things we we can be surprised also
we can have more depth than that and but
yet it doesn't mean we want to give up
like the other things that pleased us
yeah i think so i can't remember what i
was going to say before that but just
something i want to pick up on was
it seems more shallow um so i'm just
playing i'm just here playing devil's
advocate because i actually
i i am obviously female i love being
female
um but i don't really care for um labels
at all
i don't really care for them at all i
just do whatever suits me really
um but i think it's interesting um you
know you said
that the women's side is more shallow i
hear you but what are your thoughts on
this right
so somebody said to me and i think it's
pretty interesting um
someone said to me that um a man has to
work
a woman can work so
what that sort of implies is like in
society
men are hugely shamed if they
don't want to work if they want to be a
house dad house husband
you know men are hugely shamed for that
so when we talk about shallow
when we talk about break what we want in
a chivalrous manner like what is the
ideal man like
you know there's this whole idea that
like money matters and it's not so much
that money matters
it's that being able to provide matters
and
being able to provide in 2020 means
being able to you know pay a mortgage
get put food on the table and that
generally falls on the man
more than it does on the woman you know
she really
has to sort of just cook right i'm
talking real traditional
okay so i'm just getting real
traditional with this um you know
her traditional role is to cook but his
is to be able to pay for that
so for me i actually think that equally
as shallow
right like i think it's never
it's always he it's always should he pay
or should we split
it's never should she pay or should we
split
so there's a huge shallow burden on the
man
i think equally as there is on the woman
yeah i think well and that's where
it's ferocious well it's not a world
it is um and if you look at the pushback
okay so this is some pushback i've seen
is that whole like i can't trust a
pretty face
right that comment i've said that i even
never heard somebody say some rubbish
like that who can't trust a pretty
like this person has i feel like that's
issues he has on his own like what
well so if you think about it though um
women are
used as a like use their beauty
women use it themselves or people uh
like leverage it if you think about
instagram and how much
instagram is basically just a shop and
around the model like the business model
is basically beautiful women selling
things to you
yeah so now people are equating
okay that women attractiveness to being
sold
something and they should ask like
extra questions because of the aesthetic
associate like tied to it you know
there's a distrust about and women
are like if you think about it
um really people think women are
beautiful at large around the world
they just do women are beautiful women
are more beautiful than men
there's some pretty beautiful men out
there um but i
i guess i'm curious as to
like i don't know i don't know if that's
a
i don't like you said who cares who
cares on the other day of
that sort of judgment it's just the fact
that people when they have awareness of
it
and then getting over it it's the fact
that maybe this is subconscious and they
don't guys don't like feeling exploited
and they feel like they're upset yeah
i'm gonna jump in because i tried to
actually agree with you on that i was
speaking to somebody um
oh i was speaking to yeah i was being so
on crypto twitter a while ago and he was
sort of explaining to me
why there's so much backlash when women
post selfies or
whatever it is right and um he sort of
he sort of broke it down and said to me
it's because the men feel like they're
being manipulated and they're being
tricked
essentially so um they feel like you
know
you're you think that you can wave this
wand this feminine wand and will just
sort of you know fall at your feet and
then suddenly they for manipulating a
trait so
i definitely hear where you're coming
from um no i i hear where you're coming
from um
but i think deeply it's more of them
hating something about themselves
it always is that's always the case i
think that it's always the case you know
whenever somebody shows any resentment
towards you
um you know if you've literally done
nothing actually wrong then i always
think that that's just going to be a
projection of inner conflict right
so why the real question is why do men
hate like no stuff and you feel
threatened about that
i guess um i don't think i don't think
men do i think a small
group of men do but i don't think all
men do whatsoever
yeah and this is the vocal and that's
the thing about a lot of these things is
you'll get your
vocal minority that on the topic
that will speak on everyone's behalf and
that's i think
i say right back to the idea of feminism
where you have
some people in the spectrum of feminism
lots of different voices that are very
loud
and try to speak for
a lot i mean i don't know i guess i
don't know if they're trying to speak
for everybody else but they're just
they're all
it's okay where as like yeah
so there's a you're right i guess going
full circle here
is that there are good gals and good
guys out there
that just have good manners and treat
each other respectfully and
can like operate with awareness
yeah and i know i understand that and i
think you make a really good point the
way i sort of like to look at it i call
it sort of the silent majority
and the loud minority so i i wouldn't
say it's like a loud
majority i personally think from my
experience it's a loud minority
trying to speak for everyone um i think
a tweet went viral
the other day sort of saying don't hold
the door for women you know we don't
need you holding the door for us we
don't like
i mean who's really offended when i mean
would you be offended if a man offered
to hold the door for you or split the
bill
or pay for the bill yeah um
so i definitely i definitely love
every opportunity when a guy does
something to me
like she does something in which i feel
extra feminine
um and it's it's safe like it feels safe
to feel that way
it's something delightful to me about
that experience well um
so because required to feel that way
yeah one is
i mean i think it also comes in contrast
to the fact that i have to be
like i feel like i have to be actually
pretty masculine sometimes
in like not letting things get to me uh
being being the go-getter type person
that when someone makes me feel feminine
it's a
it's
i hear you and i think i can totally
relate because i think you know we're
both
career driven um so and this is
something that jordan peterson talks
about and i absolutely
really respect jordan peterson and he
sort of says you know if women want to
be successful in the workplace then they
do sort of have to adopt
traditionally masculine traditional
masculine things
like taking risks because women are less
likely to take risks
a really basic example so you know
adopting those things but then
it's also okay to sort of want what you
want and the outside of that workplace
and i think
that's something which um modern day
feminism in 2020 sort of shames women
for wanting and sort of tells men that
we don't want that which is where the
question then comes from
has feminism sort of ruined chivalry
right well and if you think about
feminism
feminism without the capital f is
the female female tendencies
just really just lastly because i know i
don't i don't want to push you on any
more questions here
but just really lastly then the term
feminism
do you not think that it has to some
extent been largely hijacked
to a point where we can't come back from
yeah
i would say probably currently i'd say
currently it is
um although you know what as all things
they operate operate on a
like almost like a pendulum swing so
once we hit
extreme on one side it'll come back to
the other side because people will push
back just in the same way that
as we go so digital with music and other
experiences that use
we've seen a uh revival of
of records and other types of physical
music you know
surging and coming back there's a
counter culture that always happens
so i think that as these trends
exist you'll see the push but i think
you and i are just an example of this
right now like why are we even having
this conversation is because the
pendulum has gone too far one side then
we're like hey wait a minute yeah so um
i guess i guess at the moment
it has that association but i wouldn't
be surprised if there was a counter
culture movement
to pull it back um i really agree with
you i just don't think it would be
called feminism
it would be the counter culture movement
it would be women sort of saying i'm not
a feminist like you know
anti-feminist anti-feminist females
speak up
it would be something like that i think
the term's just gone forever maybe
i think you'd have to get away from you
couldn't even say anti-feminist right
because it's confusing
if you're not if you're an anti-feminist
what does that mean
in a moment that'd be very interesting
um yeah
so i don't and i guess um
give us your give us your final thoughts
it doesn't have to be feminism related
we'll we'll take you out there we'll
take you out of the hot seat i apologize
final thought i'm going to put you on
full screen so you can give us your
final thoughts
real quick oh gosh okay um well i think
that the most important thing is that
we're all
unique um every person has their own
environmental
uh like components to them their own
innate talents and skills
and then also genetically and
our biology makes us who we are and
we're all like
very unique in that way so being
respectful to each other like
opening doors which everybody should
open if you have someone coming in
behind you for example you should always
open a door for them um and
being courteous and thoughtful and
understanding each other i think
the more that we work to understand our
relationships to each other
who i am to you uh how i can be
complementary always
to each other is is how we win together
and i think that should be the focus
and if someone expresses needs or
desires
listening um and and
if you want to be that for that person
then you know i think that's
the positive steps that was beautiful
i love that margarite thank you so much
it was so good chatting i'm so pleased
we finally
got to do this because we've been
talking for ages um i want to say
thank you to icon plus because they do
power this and thank you to block five
guys don't forget
i'm actually gonna leave the comment um
the i haven't done that yet i need to
leave a um
you can get basically guys you can get
25 if you sign up to block fight i
forgot to leave the link in the comments
so i'm going to put that in now so
25 if you sign up with blog phi so go
for it all right guys we'll see you
next thursday bye